long lines of people waiting for a covic
test in buenos aires
they have been waiting for hours as
authorities struggled to cope with a
rise in coveting infections
alfredo said he had a moral obligation
to get tested after coming in close
contact with a relative infected with
covet 19.
i went to a party and i've had three
vaccine shots my niece told me last
night she has covered so here i am i'm
working in an office and i have to be
responsible
the government has confirmed the omicron
variant is responsible for the rise in
infections
eric hernandez says the positivity is
alarmingly high
in total we are testing around 300
people of every 150 tests we do 50 are
positive it's a rapid test but we are
seeing the increase the city's
government started setting up these
testing sites in many parts of buenos
aires last week because of the increase
in cases
president alberto fernandez has
discarded reimposing restrictions at
least for now the number of people in
the hospitals due to covet 19 remains
low and the death rate has not varied in
the past month and that's why the
government is focusing on the progress
of the vaccination campaign that began
one year ago
many south american countries are
winning the vaccination race 63 percent
of the region's population is vaccinated
and that figure continues to increase
but analysts say omicron still poses a
serious threat to the health system
in a country like argentina where the
health system is fragile and you see
problems even in the united states you
see hospitalizations are increasing
doctors and nurses are getting sick so
the problem is double i am looking at
the charts from brazil from peru even
from chile they had a peak three weeks
ago and then it went down all i can say
is that everyone is vulnerable to this
and that's why leaders in the region are
pushing for more booster shots and
preparing for some difficult days ahead
as the omicron variant continues to
spread al jazeera buenos aires